days of unrelenting rain have left parts
of australia's most populous state new
south wales underwater
homes ruined and lives destroyed
they've had trees coming down they've
had property damaged
they've had cars ruined i've seen some
cars on my street have been
damaged by the by the rain and trees
falling
so yeah it's just been a bad time for
everyone i think
at least 40 flood warnings are in place
and tens of thousands of people have
been ordered to leave their homes
and there's more rain on the way this
potentially is a very dangerous
situation
that everyone needs to understand the
magnitude and gravity of what could
become over the coming 24 48 hours the
bureau
is not giving us great advice around the
potential rainfall that is coming and
that's obviously very perplexing
considering
that all the catchments are soaked at
the moment
it's a year since unprecedented
bushfires burned across this region
they followed a prolonged drought that
led to sydney introducing water
restrictions
now record rainfall is causing chaos the
premiere of new south wales says the
state is experiencing a 1 in 100 year
disaster
i just want to say to everybody across
the state who is currently
living in fear and anxiety that all of
us
are thinking of you some communities who
were battered by the bushfires
are now being battered by the floods and
deep drought prior to that
and i don't know any time in our state's
history when we've had these extreme
weather conditions in such quick
succession in the middle of a pandemic
and with weather experts predicting more
rain for much of this week
many people say they feel they're at
breaking point
victoria gatenbee al jazeera